israel says it put this summit together
in a few days nonetheless it clearly
wanted to convey maximum symbolism and
significance in the desert kibbutz once
home to israel's first prime minister
david ben-gurion the foreign ministers
of egypt bahrain morocco and the uae
along with the u.s secretary of state
espoused friendship and shared goals
43 years ago when egypt and israel
made peace
unfortunately we lost those 43 years
of knowing each other better of working
together and of changing the narrative
that
many generations of israelis and arabs
have been living
israel's foreign minister said this
first meeting would become a permanent
forum but he also advanced goals for the
here and now
this
new
architecture the
shared capabilities
we are building intimidates and deters
our common enemies
first and foremost iran and its proxies
there was shared condemnation of an
attack on sunday by suspected isil
linked gunman that killed two israeli
security forces personnel
on the wider security picture the u.s
secretary of state stuck to his script
not bending to israel's opposition to a
revived iran nuclear deal he did though
raised the palestinian aspiration for
statehood
these regional peace agreements are not
a substitute for progress between
palestinians and israelis one of the
issues we discussed today
was how countries involved in the
abraham accords and normalization as
well as those that have long-standing
diplomatic relationships with israel
can support the palestinian authority
and the palestinian people in concrete
ways
that was echoed by the arab foreign
ministers most explicitly by egypt
during these discussions we did
highlight the importance of the
israeli-palestinian peace process the
importance of maintaining the
credibility and the viability of the
two-state solution that for israel and a
palestinian state to live side by side
in peace
with recognized borders for a
palestinian state in accordance with the
67 lines with east jerusalem as its
capital for the palestinian leadership
however such words are just that words
they see this entire summit in this
place as an undermining of their cause
for sovereignty and independence
the palestinian prime minister focused
on what was happening inside israel
arab normalization meetings without
ending the israeli occupation of
palestine are just an illusion a mirage
and a free reward for israel
palestinian president meanwhile had his
own diplomacy to conduct welcoming
jordan's king abdullah to ramallah on a
mission to calm tensions ahead of
ramadan
harry fawcett al-jazeera southern israel
ibrahim has more on reaction to the
negev summit from ramallah in the west
bank
there is a lot of criticism by
palestinian officials that the way the
americans and some arab leaders are
dealing with this whole issue
palestinian officials have been saying
over the past few months even that we
want to engage in a political process
that ends the israeli occupation they're
refusing any talks of better living
conditions of diffusing tension while
the palestinians are still living and
feeling the brunt and the pain of being
under the israeli occupation there's a
lot of talk in the street as well
they're saying that the world is dealing
with double standards when it comes to
the palestinian we see them sympathizing
with ukrainians as they are now under
the russian occupation but turning a
blind eye when it comes to palestinians
who have been living under the israeli
occupation for decades so there's a lot
of disappointment amongst politicians
and people in the street asking to be a
part of the dialogue asking the world to
impose sanctions on israel to end its
occupation we're seeing that they're
getting some positive signs from jordan
instead of the jordanian being in the
summit we hear that they declined the
invitation and the jordanian king has
decided to meet with president abbas the
talks are mostly
discussing
coordinating efforts to defuse tension
jordan is the custodian of the holy
sites in jerusalem there are a lot of
talks about how to prevent an escalation
ahead of the holy month of ramadan